how's it gonna breasts - that's my name
that's my name say it [ __ ]
sorry I'm so sorry you're not okay
welcome to garbage day and it's uncut in
the butt you know what that means
oh boy I dropped my drink okay no matter
what happens we're not cutting the
gameplay I haven't played this game
before but the gameplay seems to be
staring at your crotch and that's like
that's a good game if you ask me that
money over there awesome
okay oh I can oh nice all right let's do
sandbox uh I don't know what the
objective is
I just know that I just left my [ __ ]
body Jesus Christ what is that what the
[ __ ] is this
what is his arm what am I supposed to do
with his arm this is a disgrace Lord has
blessed not blessed me I mean the [ __ ]
[ __ ] your chain oh my god I'm so sorry
chair oh no come back I love you you're
my only wife there you go sit there but
like how do I supposed to pleasure
myself with this
I can't even pleasure myself with a
chair I need to find a wife that she is
wife I love you I'll be right there wait
for me what the [ __ ] am i doing I don't
understand what is the timer slow mo oh
okay can i play
oh god I have talent
yes Thank You Jan I know the next most
I'm for sure can I actually play like a
song let's try it that's a soul song of
my soul let's go chair let's go and find
a new wife no don't worry about it
you're not my wife anymore
I was this buy milk should we I don't
have any food now I do
that's right chair I'm sorry I'm sorry
just be quiet please all right let's
make a breakfast cereal it is yes can I
hope yes okay let's make some cereal
this is how we do it in Sweden don't you
worry about it
now where's the cereal making button
there it is
got it and here's totally meant to do
that don't worry about it
there's just all part of the plan so the
game is called garbage day say assume
I'm supposed to take the trash out but
what then why are you still here I'm so
sorry
you're not trash you're beautiful
beautiful ah Jesus Christ what happened
punishment for my sins stop spinning
stop spinning okay this is oddly
hypnotizing I'm just gonna go with it
nice breakdancing smoo man damn chair
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you're the best I was
gonna say the best and the boss and [ __ ]
it all right we're weapons it's the goal
to just kill people I don't understand
if I had a wife why would i seduce some
wid a nice big shotgun I would say oh
god I shot chair I'm so sorry I'm tap no
she's my wife and I love her you don't
understand nope oh god oh god there no
no no I can't aim
that's right [ __ ] where to
check oh wait I see where did you take
my chair oh it's right there oh never
again
how do wait one change weapon let's do
the katana chair wake up can I swing
this yes I can
awesome chair you want to go on the the
swing let's go baby
oh here you're loving it he's loving it
am i playing the game ride I'm not sure
I swing myself
oh god my life oh my god what happened
why is it so quiet hello what happened
to the blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah aah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
okay okay
what away should i to restart maybe i
should play this seriously I'm sorry
let's try that again
alright I don't know what I'm supposed
to do like what's the goal I know it's
sandbox so maybe I'm just supposed to
[ __ ] around and [ __ ] champ champ
we spoke about this many times chair
you're the trash you're the trash no
you're the champ
no matter how many times you breakdance
I ain't falling for that
let's do this II should be sniper some
scrubs
where should we talk uh chair I'm sorry
take the gun protect us Oh God okay
don't
just don't resist don't resist how am i
adding everywhere where he's not oh
there we go Oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] they got
[ __ ] goddammit [ __ ] I'm sorry I'm
sorry
don't I'm sorry if we [ __ ] up in these
games that's what happens all right you
just gotta go back on the horse go back
on the horse in this case the horse is
the chair come on buddy
I talented is I okay let's try this
again
how about if the chair attacks blow it
sounds like a great idea for a movie
yeah he got him he got him sold now
we're we're gonna do it's not a ladder
can I go up here who all breaking bad
reference beats on the ceiling now peace
and space oh man I'm so bad ok let's say
well [ __ ] catch chop chop these
[ __ ] can I go in the car oh my God
look at that face oh [ __ ] I'm so sorry
it was in the middle of the road to be
fair and so with this man and so with
that guy you can't sue me cuz I'm
Swedish that's right can't sue us it's
the only super watch is this malice
don't mind me
don't mind me nothing illegal going on
here what is this
I feel like I still have to a lot of a
lot of choices for want wives here have
you guys seen I have wife big boobs
cooks for me every Tuesday know what
don't worry we can run run run you're
with me now you're with me now
go away there we go
no chair no chair is cheating on me hey
hey no no no no aah
ah where's chair stop it stop this
nonsense chair you come with your my
wife that's right [ __ ] [ __ ] that guy
what an [ __ ] I'm a right
go chair go chair we're gonna run away
together I love you I love you like you
were my child
okay guys okay what the [ __ ] I'm stuck
I'll come on what is this but ah I can't
ah
I'm free I'm free think I'd shut up
Jennifer how do I enter you over here
okay I swear to God when I come in now
I'm gonna bitch-slap the [ __ ] out of the
next birthday you go rolls and I lift
this up no sure
there we go you may be broken you may be
ugly but I love you you want to go in
the basketball
nail that yeah that was awesome let's
try that again with an actual basketball
hey but hey bro catch ya a nice one man
that was awesome
what am i doin so nice slow motion dunk
whoa damn it [ __ ] ah [ __ ] the ball is
lost the ball is lost shut the [ __ ] up
Jesus Christ I want to do that again
where's champ so anything I can pick up
from here melon you're my new best
friend melon I love you
we're gonna run away for look like a big
grape actually all right here we go 360
420 the [ __ ] did melon go what is that
thing flying what was that I swear to
God I saw something okay
alright this the song is over I don't
know what else to do is in this game
let's finish off with an epic 360 jump
oh shut up
foul blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah thank you for
watching on cutting the bud garbage day
this game is a game about with beautiful
aesthetics and a gameplay where you kill
stuff they'll leave like we enjoyed let
me know if you want more on cutting the
bud and then now chair we'll get the
last word alright beautiful